all right why don't we get started
professor in the Economics Department
and on behalf of the program in ethics
politics in economics I'd like to
welcome all of you to the annual Robert
H wits lecture in ethics and Social
Policy before introducing net coin from
environmental defense fund I want to
tell you a bit about Robert little it's
whose generosity made today's lecture
and the series possible Ludwick's
trained in law and then came to the Yale
Divinity School to think about the
ethical underpinnings of social policy
tragically he was diagnosed with cancer
in 1989 different people have different
responses to that situation but one of
his was to establish a charitable trust
to support interdisciplinary research
teaching and scholarship in ethics and
social policy this lecture series is a
fruit of that vision and of his generals
generous spirit were honored to have
with us today his sister
Laurie literate s-- who traveled here
from Mexico where she is an established
international artist we're also
delighted to welcome nat cohen back to
Yale where he got his BA before heading
to Harvard to do his PhD and most
recently here he was a professor in
economics and the School of Management
after that he joined the Environmental
Defense Fund where he became director of
economic policy and analysis and then
chief economist he later served in the
Obama administration as special
assistant to the president for energy in
the environment and after the White
House he returned to the Environmental
Defense Fund where he's currently senior
vice president and leader of the climate
change division I think it is ideal for
people at the frontier of academia who
are pushing forward knowledge to go to
government and share that knowledge and
bring it back to academia and this is a
phenomenal example of that economics is
often known as the dismal science but
it's good to have a response to that and
that is widely known as a voice for
optimism and climate change and a
powerful voice for using markets to
solve climate problems please join me in
welcoming that
thank you very much
Joe and can everybody hear me if I talk
like this because I may walk a little
bit so thanks very much and thanks to
its family for supporting this talk and
thanks to to ISPs for inviting me and
thanks Joe for that introduction thanks
to all of you for for coming I this was
an interesting talk to put together
because as I put it together I thought
of all these things I wanted to to
include and to talk about it's such a
rich topic and such a great audience and
even during the day as I was meeting
with folks oh I should have this I
should add this so hopefully I'll be
able to tell a coherent narrative for
you I'm gonna start with what you often
hear from environmental advocates which
is a little bit of doom and gloom
there's always wets the palate for more
but I want to start with a little bit of
the seriousness of the challenge that we
face on climate that may be familiar to
many of you but I think it's always a
good a good place to set expectations or
to set a baseline but I want to spend
most of the time talking about solutions
I thought a lot actually when I named
this when I call this solving the
climate crisis this is sort of the sub
the sub title but the solving the
climate crisis whether this is really
something we can solve or whether it's
just something we can mitigate and make
a little bit better and that might be a
great topic for discussion but one
reason I wanted to use the word solve is
because we we actually have solved
environmental problems in the past and
that gives us a hint for how we might at
least tackle climate change and I'll
tell you a story about about the one of
those one of those success stories in
the past so I will probably take the
balance of the hour and but I hope to
have plenty of time for questions and I
would encourage folks I'm a I'm an
economist I spent a lot of time in
economics seminars so I'm not perturbed
if people want to ask questions during
the talk if I were giving an economic
seminar there already would have been a
couple of questions
so so feel free if you if you have a
question and and you want to raise it
especially if it's something I'm saying
it's not clear bring that up but
otherwise we'll have plenty of time for
discussion at the end I will try to get
to the politics at the end although as
you'll see it's a little open-ended
discussion but perhaps that's also
something we can get to in the in the
question and answers afterwards so I've
started the talk with a picture of the
New Jersey coast after sandy and this is
this is hurricane sandy as it looked or
superstorm sandy as it looked on the on
the on October 29th 2012 when it made
landfall just south of New York City I
often start with this because I talked
to New York City audiences I'm from New
York and it's a kind of epical event in
New York City especially it also
illustrates some of the issues we face
in terms of climate change there were a
lot of things that contributed to sandy
in many ways it was sort of a perfect
storm but a couple of them are have at
least some link to climate change one of
them was if you if you looked at a track
this is maybe the most tenuous but still
worth noting if you looked at a track of
Sandy as it went up the coast it took it
went it was going up the eastern
seaboard and then it took a sharp left
turn and slammed into New Jersey in New
York the reason it did that was there
was a kind of mass of air that was
blocking it from going forward and there
are some theories that had actually been
published before sandy suggesting that
Arctic sea ice melt the melting of the
Arctic sea ice changes weather patterns
in a way that would that would lead to
exactly that coins that sort of blocking
mass in the northern hemisphere was that
so did the Arctic sea ice melt
contribute to sandy was it the cause it
would be too much to say that it was a
cause but it was perhaps a contributing
factor a second contributing factor why
are we talking about a hurricane in
October in the Northeast anyways
hurricanes draw their strength and
tropical storms draw their strength from
the warmth of the water and the Atlantic
the
Atlantic was or the I guess that's the
western Atlantic the eastern seaboard
was 1 to 2 degrees warmer than normal
that fall that was again a contribution
of lots of factors but one of them
undeniably the fact that the earth is
about at one and a half degrees
Fahrenheit warmer than it was in
pre-industrial times and those warm
waters contributed to the force and the
energy that were involved in the storm
the last one is maybe best illustrated
by this picture this is for those of you
have driven in New York this is the
battery this is in the south the south
the southern part of something tip of
Manhattan and that's water washing over
the the wall next to the Brooklyn
Battery Tunnel and flooding that tunnel
and the most devastating part of
hurricane sandy or superstorm sandy in
New York City of course there was huge
devastation in New Jersey and in Long
Island but the most devastating part in
Manhattan was the swampy of the tunnels
and the subways here's a picture of the
Lexington Avenue subway I had to double
check that this is a real picture and
not photoshopped I actually often ride
this I go to the station now and it
doesn't usually look like this
the reason though New York City subways
flood when the water level reaches 10
and a half feet above mean low tide mark
they had never flooded before and if you
look at a history of storms in the night
in the 20th century you'll see some
reaching 10 feet some to reaching 9 and
a half but sandy was the first one that
topped the ten and a half foot now
there's lots of reasons for that
it was a high tide full moon a whole
bunch of like I said a perfect storm but
one contributing factor is that the sea
level at the battery is about 15 inches
taller 15 inches higher than it was in
pre-industrial times and that's directly
attributable to climate change
so with Sandy due to climate change it's
too much to say that but where they're
contributing factors certainly and this
is certainly the kind of storm that we
might see more of in New York that we
might see more of on the East Coast that
we might see more of globally in coastal
areas and it's just one example of the
kind of impacts that we're seeing
already from
warming climate so what I want to do now
is talk a little bit what is happening
in why I'm not a climate scientist but I
I know many climate scientists I'll give
you a little flavor I'm not going to
spend the whole time on climate science
but I think it's important to say a
little bit about what's going on to make
sure we're all on the same page this is
an exist you know I could come up with
many examples this is one just to say
that what's happening in Sandy is not an
aberration the warm weather we you know
the warm weather we've increasingly
experienced in the northern hemisphere
is not a deviation or an anomaly this is
the trend this is now I'm gonna go back
and forth between Celsius and Fahrenheit
because that's often what the sources
I'm using are so this is now Celsius
this is the trend over the period 1901
to 2012 so kind of pre-and us you know
at least beginning of the 20th century
before we really had seen a lot of
warming as a result of fossil fuel
emissions what you see is warming
everywhere you also see that the average
temperatures we often talk about mask a
live variation so in some places like
much of Brazil and South America some
northern the northern latitudes in the
northern hemisphere subparts of Saharan
and sub-saharan Africa the measured
warming has been 2 and 1/2 degrees
Celsius over that period the average
warming around it was if you averaged
land and sea is about point eight over
this period so we're seeing warming and
we're seeing that distinct signal one
fact that I often hear is that the last
month so if you look at the average
monthly temperature over the 20th
century the last time that a month were
in the United States that were the last
time that a month was less than the
average temperature then that 20th
century average was in the 1980s so if
you've heard about Little Lake Wobegon
where everybody is smart all the kids
are smarter and and and stronger than
average we're in a world where all the
months are hotter than average because
we're changing the average and we're
changing the world and so why is that
well simply put yeah
so this I think is that's a good it's a
good question of where the data comes
from this is IPCC yeah I think they're I
think there's some extrapolation in
those those are pretty big you know
areas and there's got to be some
uncertainty associated with it but the
trend globally is on yeah yeah so this
is a picture I think it's always useful
to ground this in what's the reality of
actually going on so these are the
observations that are taken and Mauna
Loa Observatory in in Hawaii at the top
of mount Aloha and they this is you may
have heard this term it's called the
Keeling curve it's a measurement of the
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere so
carbon dioxide is the main greenhouse
gas that we're you know if you if you
want to know why the and I'll talk more
about this in a few slides but why is
the earth warming it's because we're
putting in gases that trap heat carbon
dioxide is the most important one but
there are others methane
hydrofluorocarbons and others this is a
direct measurement of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere at Mont Aloha from 1958
until I pulled this off the web last
night and that's the most recent
measurement so you see a pretty steady
upward march that's directly in line
with the co2 emissions that were putting
into the atmosphere
the other interesting thing one of the
fascinating things about the Keeling
curve is you see the interest you see
the inter-annual variation the ups and
the downs I love this curve in part
because that's a picture of the Earth's
respiration this is the northern
hemisphere so in the summer plants are
growing and they're pulling carbon
dioxide out of the air and in the winter
they're decaying and they released the
leaves drop the leaves they release that
back end you can see that variation I
always think that's one of the marvelous
things about this curve but the main
thing about this curve is greenhouse gas
emissions co2 emissions a particular
I think putting this in historic and
historical context these are all from
Scripps is really interesting so here's
this was so this is the last 60 years
where we have measurements directly from
on Aloha this is
last 300 years using ice core data
before that Manalo a time series so you
see okay at least in the last 300 years
what we're doing is pretty sharp anomaly
verson Amelie versus what carbon dioxide
emissions looked like for most of that
period of time of course this covers
some of the Industrial Revolution so
what if we look at the last 10,000 years
what we see is basically greenhouse gas
emissions or co2 emissions staying
constant just until the very end when we
start burning co2 emitted when we
started running fossil fuels and you see
this spike showing up and then we can
even go back 800,000 years and even over
that time period where there's been lots
of ups and downs and fluctuation what
we're doing for the atmosphere what
we're putting to the atmosphere is
beyond any anything that humans have
experienced in history or pre recorded
history so we're entering into new
totally fundamentally new territory and
something like hurricane sandy maybe is
only one small sign I'll talk about some
others how do we know that it's human
influence by the way I want to have a
couple of slides on that again this
isn't the science talk but I think it's
always useful to know that especially
for those of you who are talking with
friends and colleagues and you may have
people who say well I've heard we don't
really know if it's human influence yes
maybe the earth is warming but how do we
know if people responsible you even hear
that nowadays from the administrator of
the Environmental Protection Agency so
how do we know a couple of things but
these are just two that I'd like to pick
out there are many many many more pieces
of evidence actually I should say the
first one is it's basically simple
chemistry and physics we know that
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases capture heat if they didn't there
wouldn't be life on the planet so we
know they capture heat and we know we're
putting more into the atmosphere and so
even that this basic chemistry and
physics tells us we ought to be seeing
some impact and it's and so we can also
test that with models these are the
observed temperatures global average
temperatures since 1900 if we look at
the changes in natural
actors that we understand volcanoes
sunspots water vapor a whole bunch of
things that contribute to temperatures
you can see that you know in the first
part they can expect you know being very
early on maybe they track but you can't
explain the more recent rise in
temperature looking at natural factors
alone
other than the influence of human
factors and so one strong piece of
evidence is that the only way based on
all our understanding about atmospheric
physics and chemistry and everything
else the only way we can understand the
rise and temperatures that we're seeing
is if we take into account of human
influence and in particular of co2
emissions there's one other piece of
evidence I'll just mention because I
find it so fascinating and this is you
know if you're looking to a sort of
smoking gun or a fingerprint again this
is I'm not laying out the whole case I'm
just mentioning a couple of things that
I think are particularly interesting and
might be useful in conversations with
with folks this is to me is one of the
most interesting ones if you you know
one of the things that climate skeptics
will say is well maybe this is variation
in the radiation that's coming out from
the Sun this is sunspots as variation in
radius we're just getting more of these
you know if you look back in ancient
history there's all sorts of cycles you
know temperature was rising and falling
way before humans got involved maybe
this is just a change in the Earth's
orbit or a change in sunspots or
something like that so if this were
about solar radiation there's a very
nice testable hypothesis here right if
what's happening is that we're getting
more solar radiation then if you looked
across the entire atmosphere you should
see warming everywhere and especially at
high altitudes but you should see
warming throughout the atmosphere if
what's happening is that we're putting
in a blanket of heat trapping gases then
you would expect warming to be below
that blanket closer to the earth and
you'd expect no warming or maybe even
cooling outside the blanket and this
shows you that that's exactly what we
see troposphere this is closer to the
earth stratosphere so this is underneath
the blanket stratosphere further away
it's exactly the fingerprint
that you would expect to see if in fact
what's happening is we're putting
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere and
that's the warming we're seeing so we
see cooling in the stratosphere so
temperature's going down we see warming
in the troposphere temperature's going
up like I said this is this is not what
the you know argument around climate
change wrestling but it's one of the
most interesting fingerprints and sort
of smoking guns that I've come across
I could put many more I'm not going to
take the time to do that but the science
behind the attribution of what we're
observing in terms of warming what we're
serving in terms of sea level rise is
really beyond doubt okay so where are we
headed I mentioned before that we've
seen about a degree and a half in terms
of fare and now we're back to Fahrenheit
but one and a half degrees Fahrenheit
rise in global temperatures so far
relative to 1900 that's reflected in
this this is the same observed trend
you've seen before this is sort of what
the model can explain but look at the
black line those are the same
observations I've shown you the blue red
and violet or purple line pink lines
show where emissions might be going of
course there's a lot of uncertainty
around that those are all different
scenarios the blue one is a relatively
optimistic one that we start to reduce
emissions the red one and the pink one
are obviously less optimistic those all
reflect assumptions about growth
population growth economic growth and so
on but what you see is relative to so
this is zeroed out at basically 1980 to
2000 the zero line is you see that it
starts below that and that's that's
included in the degree and a half so
we're looking at at a minimum under
these scenarios and there many more at a
minimum four degrees Fahrenheit increase
but I will tell you that this is a
pretty optimistic scenario about this is
this includes a lot of policies in in
play if we don't do anything we're
looking much more at a 7 to 8 degree
fahrenheit increase and now if you go
back to the map I showed earlier you
know a little less than 1 degree Celsius
in some places you've seen 2
1/2 degrees Celsius increase so an
average increase global temperatures of
78 degrees Fahrenheit for 4 and 1/2
degrees Celsius that could lead to much
larger average increases i sorry much
larger localized increases in
temperatures so we're heading as I said
into uncharted territory what what does
that look like so there's been some
estimates to sort of do some projections
around what the impacts would be I'll
talk a little bit about what those
projections look like I also have some
economics on that at the end but I want
to start with or in after a couple
slides I want to start with what the
projections look like some of the best
projections have been done as part of
something called the risky business
product project a group called the
rhodium group did County level estimates
of things like warming or a number of
days in this case above 95 degrees so a
lot of what you hear when people like me
to talk about climate change they talk
about averages global averages we talked
about local versus global but they also
talk about averages over the year and
that can be misleading because you think
to yourself well you know two degrees
Celsius three degrees Celsius
you know it's warmer it's like when I
woke up this morning in New York and I
went for a run it was you know clearly
seven or eight degrees Fahrenheit cooler
than it is now you know so that doesn't
feel like such a big deal but the
average is also mask extremes and if
you're essentially what we're doing is
we're making everything warmer and that
means the average is warmer but it also
means that the number of hot days goes
way up for those of you think about the
students in the room you think about a
probability distribution imagine a bell
curve of the number of days at any given
temperature temperatures along the
x-axis frequency on the y-axis so
temperature is broadly speaking
distributed like a bell curve what we're
doing is we're shifting the whole bell
curve up and that means the little area
on the right-hand side of the bell curve
that indicates how many days what the
probability of really hot days is that's
getting much much larger this shows that
for the u.s. for one projection here's
that base period 1980 to 2000
number of days above 95 degrees the this
red is 150 this pink is 125 so you see
you know in the baseline most places
it's you know zero to ten above 95 on
average doesn't seem right for New York
City but maybe I guess we're in the 0 to
10 range but you do see some areas that
get hot this is what the projection
looks like at least under this
particular projection for the end of the
century what you see is that the areas
where there's a hundred to 125 days
above 95 degrees a third of the year
above 95 degrees that's most of the
south the southeastern United States
and we're looking at places parts of
Texas in Arizona where you've got 200
250 days above 95 degrees so first point
is you think about averages that can be
misleading because we're talking about
extreme temperatures that are going to
get much more common what does that look
like in terms of impacts again drawing
on some of the same data this is now
from a paper that was published in
science last year but with many of the
people on the rhodium group who had
worked on that risky business project as
well as some others people at Berkeley
at University of Chicago these haven't
come out that well but you can see that
that's a map of the US and you can read
the bottom line which is if you look at
changes in crop yields across the
country and you estimate that again at a
fine grain level there's lots of
uncertainty here but this is this is the
trend we can expect you do see you know
if you look across the US there's lots
of variation some places may be crop
yields will increase that's the green
part but in the breadbasket of Illinois
Iowa Kansas you are getting estimated
yield reductions of 30 to 30 50 even up
to 90 percent so huge impacts this is
just the US where that fine-grained
estimate has been done but you could see
the same things in other countries so
huge impacts in crop yields this is an
estimate of labor productivity
particularly for for work that takes
place outside measureable decreases in
labor productivity especially in the
areas that are going to be most subject
to heat
mortality turns out to be a huge part of
the damages it used to be thought that
well you know earthworms you'll have
fewer you'll have more hot days but you
have fewer cold days it all balances out
it turns out if you look at mortality
rates there that heat is a much worse
killer than cold and so if we have an
increase in hot days and heat waves
across the US you can see a measurable
increase in mortality if you think about
ecosystems some of you may have read
recently in the New York Times about the
Great Barrier Reef which nudist you know
new assessments have shown widespread
bleaching potentially irreversible and
the Great Barrier Reef I always tell my
students I'd still teach a class at NYU
and in New York you know if you want to
see the Great Barrier Reef you better go
soon because it is gone it is not gonna
last and the rest of the world's coral
reefs are serious risk if we continue on
the current trajectory we always have to
have a polar bear 20 to 30 species a
percent of species at risk of extinction
within the century okay so that's kind
of the gloom and doom part of the talk
and the summary is the world is warming
we're responsible and if we don't do
anything about it the impacts are really
significant and that's only beginning to
scratch the surface so what are we gonna
do about it well I want to start because
I'm in Corona so I want to talk a little
bit first about some of the economics
and then I'll talk about some of the
solutions which are wrapped up of course
in the economics you know we can one way
to think about the economics and we'll
economics will be a running thread
through all of this because it's also
behind policy design and solutions but
of course economics is also about
assessing the monetary value of things
that's not all it is but that's one one
contribution it can make and so there's
been a number of economic estimates
these are just a few models these are
the names of the models that's why they
sound funny that have attempted to take
all the impacts I just described to crop
yields actually mortality is a new thing
and
the these estimates don't actually take
into account that degree of mortality
but crop yields the value of ecosystem
loss sea level rise and the threat to
coastal properties thought forest fires
warming tempered you know the effect of
warming on a whole range of things in
terms of economic productivity but also
in terms of the value people have for
economic for ecosystems and and the
economy if you try to add all that up
you put it into models and then you
express it in terms of the percent loss
in global GDP as a function of
temperature needless to say there's lots
of assumptions behind this but it's a
useful metric well if you look at again
in the range that we were talking about
before four to five degrees this is
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
levels remember we already risen 0.8 so
this is roughly in the range of where
some mid-level projections would have us
land by the end of the century under
current course you see economic damages
you know it's a pretty wide range but
centered in that three to five percent
of global GDP that's a big number that's
a significant percentage of global
output and so that's one way of thinking
about the damages that I've been
monetary value in the economic value of
the damages and you can see that if it's
worse than that and I'll talk about risk
in a minute but if it's worse if it
turns out to be five or six degrees
you know the estimates rise to ten
percent some of the more pessimistic
models having to be in the double digits
percent of GDP one way to mature thing
about this is what is each of us
contribute so this is a this is you know
a visual of that if if you thought about
the Sun that what a ton of co2 at
atmosphere at ground level atmospheric
pressure would look like that's about
how that's about how big an area volume
it would take up okay so these people
you can see if you take the damages I
just showed and you apply there's lots
of assumptions behind this but if you
follow the US government main line
assumptions on what that means for the
cost of every ton of greenhouse gases
that we put into the atmosphere today
what's that cost if you think about all
these damages that are happening in the
future
think about this happening every time
every year into the future take all of
that stream of costs and attribute it to
what what's the cost of every tonne
we're putting into the atmosphere the
number you get is about $48 in current
dollars now even that a lot of people
including myself would say that's
probably too low the first time the US
government did this in 2011 it came up
with a number this this is these are
numbers that the Obama administration
did in 2015-2016 the first time they did
the exercise the number was about half
of that just in the space of a few years
the models had advanced enough to
increase it by this much there are some
other assumptions in there that some
people think are too conservative so you
could easily imagine under reasonable
assumptions that this number is 70 80
$100 but let's use relatively
conservative US government under the
Obama administration this is called the
social cost of carbon what is the cost
in terms of that the cost to the society
of every time that's emitted of co2 or
other greenhouse gases in a co2 metric
$48 so in the u.s. we're each
responsible for 16 and a half tonnes per
year that's our average that's higher
not higher than every other country but
higher than almost every other country
just to put it in perspective most of
Europe is I think the European average I
left off my head but it's around 10 or
11 France is 7 there's a lot of nuclear
power China is now 7 tons a year
India is less than 2 it gives you some
sense of the disparities so in the u.s.
we emit about if you if you take total
greenhouse gas emissions in u.s. you
divide by the number of people so very
simple per person it's about that's 48
times 16 and a half eight eight hundred
dollars so that's about the cost again
using that fairly conservative factor
that each of us that's are like internal
carbon footprint I will tell you my
carbon footprint is a lot more than this
and the number one reason is because I
fly a lot so if you're one this is not
going to be a talk about individual
actions so much as these about global
policy but if you're thinking about your
own impact flying is the number one for
any for anybody in the room flying is
your is the number one probably
carbon footprint anyway $800 vo that's
basically the damage that on average
each of us in the u.s. is imposing on
everybody else now before I start
talking about policy solutions and how
we're going to get at this I do want to
talk about one thing that's been
implicit so far because a lot of these
numbers I put out there I put out there
as if there's a single number forty
eight dollars eight hundred dollars for
degrees in fact and I've said this
implicitly or I've said this a couple of
times that I want to make it explicit
this is really a problem about risk
because there's deep uncertainties in
everything that I've talked about
there's uncertainties in how fast US
emission sorry how fast global
greenhouse gas emissions will rise over
the coming century one of the
technologies available what's the
economic growth its population
there's uncertainties in how long and in
how that those emissions will translate
into temperature so scientists don't
know for sure because we're entering
into uncharted territory we don't know
for sure how much let's say a doubling
of greenhouse gas concentration in the
atmosphere what that leads to in terms
of temperature I will tell you the
longer we go on we're able to bound that
on the lower side okay so we now are
pretty sure we can tell you that
doubling co2 at makan sensation of co2
in the atmosphere definitely gives you
at least 1 degree because we haven't
gotten to double yet and we're already
one degree higher right so the longer we
wait the more we learn about that that
distribution of the sensitivity of the
climate but we did but there still
uncertainty there there's uncertainty on
impacts there's uncertainty on the value
of those impacts uncertainty is
everywhere so rather than thinking about
one number that you might have and
Robbie and Dana if you want to sit I
just happen to know you also I can tell
you my name I don't know so if you
wanted to if you if you want to think
about risk that's really the better way
to think about it so this is a I love
this sort of heuristic this is the folks
that MIT put this together a few years
ago the numbers I will tell you I'll
explain the numbers in a minute the
numbers here in terms of projected
temperature rise were at the time they
were fairly high-end in other words they
were
probably higher projected temperature
increases than most other models and
this was also done 10 years ago so what
I want you to think about is the message
about risk rather than the exact number
it's because the message about risk
still holds true so what is the message
well so the way to think about climate
in general and this is going to help us
think about the solutions is not that
we're on a fixed path we know where
we're going and if we do X Y & Z we go
to somewhere else and we know where that
is and that's an easy calculation the
reality is there's huge amounts of
uncertainty and therefore a huge amounts
of risk and so the way to think about
outcomes is like a roulette wheel so
that's what this is okay so you've got
some small sliver of chance this is like
1% that we under current this again
these are these numbers are 10 years old
but without policy you know we could get
really lucky maybe the climates not a
sensitive issue flaw as we thought maybe
technologies rained down despite the
policies that would despite not having
policies maybe economic growth is slower
than we think whatever that wouldn't be
lucky but it could be let fewer
emissions so maybe we get lucky and
temperature is less the temperature
increased by the end of the century is
less than 3 degrees you know there's
maybe what what is that looks like a 10
to 12 percent chance these are the size
of these pies is sort of the probability
that you land right so maybe we spin the
wheel and we get lucky and we land on
the 3 to 4 degree Celsius
wedge so then you know that could happen
but it could also happen that we spin
the wheel and we land in the 5 to 6
degrees which is in there modeling was
the most likely outcome well pretty much
on a par with 4 to 5 and it's even
possible that whether it's because of
economic trends or technology trends or
a climate that's much more sensitive
than we expect we could spin the dial
and get to more than 7 degrees by the
end of the century Celsius so 7 degrees
Celsius is 12 degrees 11 degrees
Fahrenheit no more than that sorry 9/5
so it's 4 13 13 degrees that's not only
off the charts that
kind of beyond imagining again these
numbers the numbers are high but the
idea that what we're doing is we're
spinning a roulette wheel and we don't
know whether we're gonna get lucky or
really unlucky or somewhere in between
that's the way to think about this this
is a problem of risk not of certainty
and so the the policy problem is how do
we transform this roulette wheel into
this one which again is uncertain but at
least improves our odds of being in a
better place again the particular
members here are based on particular
policies but the idea I want you to come
away with is this is a question of risk
so how do we think about this well I'll
start by saying the way I I was having a
conversation with Detlef earlier there's
often a lot of conversation and a lot of
focus on what happens at the end of the
century what's our target for 2100
what's our target for the long term can
we keep emissions ever from rising below
two degrees that's the standard goal you
here among environment lab Achatz Kim
what's the 20 the 2050 target I actually
there's a useful targets to think about
the long run because this is a long run
problem but I think if we're really
starting to think about how we solve
this problem we need to start thinking
about what we do now and so I like to
think about this in terms of turning the
corner on global emissions and getting
on a downward path and that was the
first that first part of my title was
turning the corner to climate safety
this is just a there was some modeling
behind it but it's not really a modeling
graph it's really an illustration this
was done a few years ago I wouldn't
worry too much about the specific
numbers but it gives you the idea the
real challenge here is not to get on one
particular emissions path or one
particular you know level of you know
one particular technology it's to stop
the rise and emissions peak and get on a
downward path as soon as we can and once
we do that there's a lot more we need to
do to drive emissions down and this is
getting emissions down this trajectory
to the safe area is going to be really
challenging in itself but I think it's
often useful to think about what's it
going to take to turn the corner and
part of that is because imagine what it
would be like if we were winning the
fight on climate
instead of losing it so that if you read
every year about how emissions were
lower than they had been the previous
year rather than we've got this
inexorable rise I think the signal that
would send to markets the signal that
would send the psychological signal
would be an enormous leap our Fallone
plus it's a necessary step it's not a
sufficient one but give me any long-term
target two degrees one and a half
degrees zero net carbon by 2050 the
first thing we need to do is to turn the
corner so I often want to focus on that
which is not to the exclusion of what we
need in the long run but it's what do we
need to do right away and how soon can
we make that turn happen so a few years
ago an Environmental Defense Fund we
took a look at this this this was from
three or four years ago this was not
really sophisticated modeling it was
sort of back of the envelope but what we
looked at was okay could we make that
turn happen by 2020 now it's 2018 now
and we did this four years ago so it
gets harder with every passing day but
you know you could still do the same
analysis and think about 2021 2022 what
we found is that if what we're focusing
on is make is turning that corner
there's really a handful of things that
could make an enormous difference so we
looked at across sort of a couple dozen
things we you know got about ten that
really stood out three of them
performing you know dealing with China's
energy sector and capping that and
reducing emissions in China and dealing
with forests turn out to be some by
themselves about half of the emissions
reductions that you could that you would
need to turn the corner the point of
this is it's not to say these things are
easy but this is an this is a global
problem but it's one that you could
address tackling in a couple of
concentrated places and this is one of
the things I was having a discussion
with someone earlier a my own optimist
or a pessimist well I'm an optimist
about the opportunities we have to turn
the corner and to start reducing
greenhouse gas emissions if we put the
resources to work that are needed - ok
so let me talk a little bit more about
solutions and what they look like you
know in very concrete terms this is my
slide that shows all the different
things we might think about doing to
reduce emissions so we need to think
about power plants and train
rotation and Industry and forests so if
you get really into the weeds you might
think you know and often people are
thinking about sectors and what they're
doing and what are the specific things
we need to do so I want to tell a couple
of stories that are going to illustrate
what the way I think we need to think
about this a little bit differently the
first is is this one and I'm curious
whether anyone knows what this is a
picture of or can guess this is a
picture of a clock and it's very
interesting clock because it's the at
least the the model that now exists
somewhere in you know Greenwich England
I don't know if that's actually the
first clock but it's a clock that was
built by a clock maker clock maker named
John Williams I think that's his name
but that's what I recollect his name
being so if you Wikipedia you might get
a different answer but I'm gonna go with
John Williams so in the early 18th
century in the late 17th century Britain
of course was the naval power the
biggest technological challenge of the
time at least one of the biggest ones
was determining longitude at sea if
you've ever been on a you know many of
you've been you know hiking or you been
out sailing you know there's farming
latitude it's pretty easy you can figure
out you know how high is the Sun in the
sky at noon that can give you a good
sense of latitude but longitude is much
more difficult so the British Parliament
created a prize to the first person who
could demonstrate a reliable method of
determining longitude at sea and the
reason I bring this up is because the
smart money as it were was on star
charts so a huge amount of investment
and resources put into compiling nightly
star logs and a huge tome this is
Greenwich Observatory that's why we have
Greenwich Mean Time as the mean as the
as the prime meridian at the Greenwich
Observatory a huge amount of effort was
put into determining the star charts so
that you could take this tome with you
on a ship and compare the Stars you saw
at night with the Stars as they would
look that evening in Greenwich and then
back out how far away you were from
Greenwich but of course that relies on a
clear night and ability to discern the
constellations John Williams this
realized that if you had a clock that
always kept time in Greenwich you could
as long as you could observe noon
wherever you were you could calculate
the difference between your local time
and the time in Greenwich and you could
use that time difference to figure out
how far away in terms of longitude you
were from England and nobody had thought
you could make a clock that worked that
well until he actually figured out how
to do it now there's a apologue to the
story as it took him forever to get the
prize money from the Parliament but the
reason I tell this story and the reason
I think about it is because this is in
part a going to be a challenge about how
we develop the kinds of innovative
technologies and the innovative
approaches to using those technologies
that can help us not only turn the
corner but drive emissions down and
there's often a temptation to come up
with you know what all the smartest
people think is the right way to do it
and to come up with right that the path
of that of these are the X things we
need to do and to something said I sort
of just showed you one version of that
but what we really need to do is not get
a lot of smart people in a room who can
say here's the way too deep
decarbonisation we need to create the
economic incentives like the prize that
john williams responded to we need to
take create the economic incentives to
it get other people to figure out what
those solutions are so that's going to
be a main theme of how we of how we
solve it okay so so how do we solve it
well you know one possibility would be
you just tell people to be better I
found this on the I was actually very
proud of finding this on them online I
was thinking I really want like somebody
speaking into a megaphone about
exhortation and then I found this Google
is an amazing technology so one thing
you know maybe we just tell people to be
better and tell people to be less
selfish and less self-interested I think
we have a pretty long track right of
figuring out that's not going to be that
effective so some of that you know
appealing to people's better angels is
going to be important and environmental
groups do a lot of that and we can try
to change norms but fundamentally the
problem is really that each of us with
everything we do go about doing in our
daily lives is putting that eight
hundred dollars worth of carbon dioxide
and
the greenhouse gases into the air and we
don't see that we don't pay about $800
cost that cost is spread out over the
whole rest of society so we're going
about our daily lives driving flying you
know burning natural gas using
electricity that burns coal all those
activities have a huge impact on other
people but we don't see that and that's
the fundamental problem and just telling
people to be better and to behave better
is not going to solve that fundamental
problem of of incentives and what
economists call externalities so I like
to think about the problem is a one of a
lining human nature how people actually
are with Mother Nature what we want to
behave well how we want them to behave
so how do we create the incentives that
create alignment between people's own
what they're doing in their lives and
their self-interest with the with the
protection and the security of the
planet well one option might be let's
come up with a bunch of international
agreements so this is a picture of the
main principles at the in December 2015
at the Paris agreement was signed act
just after it was gaveled through this
is Laura Ljubljana
who is a special envoy of France
Christiana Figueres head of the UN
Framework Convention on Climate Change
un secretary-general ban ki-moon Laurel
abuse is the French Foreign Minister who
chaired the talks that's Boland who was
the French president so they're
celebrating the Paris agreement and the
Paris agreement actually was a
significant development I was in Paris
there had a very small role as one of
the in whether the NGOs advocating for
different parts of it so the Paris
agreement really is a high watermark of
international diplomacy and it's not
going to be nearly enough so the Paris
agreement is like the best thing that's
ever come out of 21 years of
international negotiations on climate
and if you look at the best modeling we
have and you asked you this is now
another graph of emissions so what does
this tell you well this tells you here's
where we were headed emissions going way
up here's where Paris would take us even
under a pretty optimistic assumption so
this actually parents all the pledges
that were made
like countries in Paris and actually you
continue on that path so this is
actually more than Paris it's Paris plus
continued ambition and then this is the
path we need to take if we're to meet
the Paris agreement goals of keeping
emissions of keeping the rise and
temperatures below 2% so you can see
where you know Paris is a big
improvement over what we were doing but
there's a long way to go
so just to having the international
agreements we're gonna need to do more
than that or we need to find a way to
implement them more effectively one of
these I really like about this chart is
that it shows you this probabilistic
outcome so that may be a little bit deep
to dive into but I think it's it's one
of the things I like about this most so
it's not simply saying well here's the
trajectory we need to be on it's saying
if you're on this trajectory there's a
range of outcomes like that green house
gamble I showed you and what Paris is
doing is it's shifting the probabilities
away it's making the probability of
higher than four degrees much smaller
but you still this is the probability of
less than two degrees it's still very
very small so Paris has shifted the
probabilities in the right direction but
there's a lot more to go if we want to
limit the probability of three degrees
or more warming so okay so international
agreements are going to be important but
they're not going to be sufficient by
themselves what about technology what
about just relying on technology there's
great news here and actually one of the
really incredible things that's happened
in the last decade or two has been the
remarkable reduction in cost of solar
and wind power this shows you wind power
costs from 1980 this is per cents per
kilowatt hour for in the US but you see
some of the things globally so the cost
of wind power has gone down by a factor
of 10 in the past in the 30 years from
1980 to 2010 huge that's an incredible
success story right it's the wind is now
competitive wind is cheaper than coal in
most of the US and in much it actually
all the USA really and and in much of
the u.s. its its competitive with
natural gas in places like India wind in
some places more compared
than fossil fuels so that's a huge story
solar power you see something similar
even more dramatic in terms of the cost
the costs have declined tremendously
these are really important this is
really important technological trend and
it's happened for a function it's a
bunch of things some of it is
technological changes that happen
regardless some of it is policies well
designed and not so well designed that
have that have led to investment in
these sectors so that's a huge success
story and sorry you also see investment
in renewables is outpacing fossil and
nuclear so not just the costs are
falling but you're also seeing
investment that so these the
multicolored bars or global investment
in this is in electric power but solar
and wind and hydro power and and bio
power outpacing fossil fuel and nuclear
so that you know we could have a debate
about nuclear I don't want it I mainly
am gonna focus on renewables versus
fossil that's also great news more money
going in super here's what the picture
looks like though in current global
energy demand just two percent or so is
met with renewable fuels with with
renewables and biofuels now
nuclear is another two and a half
percent and so you know again there's a
discussion there it's a zero carbon
which is a big plus there are some other
renewables a lot of this is bio so
biomass is really most of this big hydro
so okay so other other renewables are a
little bigger piece of the puzzle but
the point is that that those cost curves
I showed you about wind and solar are
dramatic and yet it's still a tiny
fraction and the magnitude of the
investment that's needed is enormous so
the investment that's going to mean
needed going forward this is one
estimate from the international energy
efficient Energy Agency the investment
needed in renewables nuclear power
carbon capture and sequestration which
allows fossil to be zero carbon electric
vehicle biofuels efficiency that
investment is enormous there's a huge
amount that needs to be done so
technology is going to be critical but
technology by itself is now
gonna save us so what do we need we need
economic incentives this is an estimate
of so these this is estimated in
basically investment so energy efficient
you know technologies whether that's an
industry or in home heating or you know
in commercial heating and air
conditioning often cost more upfront and
so this I think this is a reflection of
the capital investment up front some of
that you would get back in terms of
savings but the point is a huge amount
of money needs to go into investment in
that new capital and in new equipment so
okay so back to this theme of meeting
economic incentives so I'm going to tell
you another story and then I'm gonna
wrap up and and probably save the
politics for the for the QA but this is
a story I have to tell because it it's
one story that gives us hope that we
have a policy solution that can help
I'll say right away the story that I'm
going to tell is it a smaller scale than
the global scale of global warming but
it's a really compelling story so in the
1980s acid rain was one of the leading
environmental issues in United States
this is a picture of a forest in the
Adirondacks the problem was that
coal-fired power plants like this one
we're emitting lots of sulfur dioxide
pollution this one this is the Mount
Storm power plant I went on Google you
know now to be fair this is steam but it
still is more dramatic so I always like
but do you know let's be fair but the
the the mouth storm power plant is big
enough you know you can see the plume
from Google and if you've flown over as
many of you I'm sure have let's say from
New York to Chicago or to the west coast
you've if you've if you've looked out
the window on a clear day you can see
all of these are power plants coal-fired
power plants in the confluence of the
Ohio the Kanawha River right this is oh
this is Pennsylvania Ohio West Virginia
the heart of US coal country all those
plants were putting sulfur dioxide
pollution into the air
some of them were being cleaned up but
most of them were not and that sulfur
pollution was going north to the to the
Adirondacks
it was also it by the way creating
particulate pollution in the East Coast
but we didn't know that as much so in
1990 George Bush the Republican in to
law a program that created a
cap-and-trade program that I'll talk
about in a minute here's what when he
signed the law here's what acid
z-position look like so I don't have the
scale on this but you know red is bad so
this is like lots of acid deposition so
sulfur dioxide makes sulfates comes down
and acid rain this is showing you that
all through in fact all through the
Midwest and up into the Adirondacks and
the Green Mountains and so on you had
really significant acid deposition
issues this is what it looked like when
George HW Bush signed that bill and this
is what it looked like 20 years later by
2011 Vincent essentially solved this
problem and it was done through that
1990 Clean Air Act amendment and
specifically the cap-and-trade program
I'll talk about moreover we didn't know
at a time in 1990 when George HW Bush
signed that bill we didn't know that
that same sulphate pollution along with
nitrate with nitrous dioxide nitrous
oxides rather was but the sulfur
pollution in particular was contributing
to particulate matter pollution in New
York City or along the eastern seaboard
and the big cities of the East Coast and
so cleaning up the sulfur pollution to
clean up the acid rain also save
hundreds of thousands of lives this is a
map that shows based on model estimates
it shows the improvement in particulate
matter and darker is better what you see
you know you're not going to know that
the scale is not gonna be easy to
understand but basically along the
population centers of the East Coast New
York what Boston you see in additions in
the Midwest you also cleaned up the air
and that's saved hundreds of thousands
of lives so when I say maybe we should
think about solving an environmental
problem solving climate change can be a
lot harder than solving acid rain but
we've done it in this case so how did
that work and what does that solution
look like well and we're getting to the
end luckily and then we'll have plenty
of time for questions
fundamentally remember that I said the
the fundamental part of the problem is
is that people are emitting this carbon
dioxide or in that case sulfur pollution
and it bears it imposes a cost and
everybody else but they don't see that
cost in their own lives they don't think
about that cost and their own decisions
it's an externality as economists say so
how are we going to solve it well there
needs to be some way to reflect that
cost to your own actions so that the
flight you take is more expensive
because of the carbon dioxide it emits
so that driving is a little bit more
expensive so that coal-fired electricity
is a lot more expensive there needs to
be some way to reset the balance to make
low-carbon alternatives whether it's
power or industrial processes or saving
the forests cheaper than the high carbon
alternatives to see that cost reflected
so that we can all make our own
decisions and then respond in terms of
developing new solutions so there are a
couple ways to do that and we can talk
about this in more detail in the
question and answer one way would be to
put a price directly through a tax
another way is to create a market in the
pollution and then the trading in that
market creates a price for pollution
that serves the same role as that tax we
can talk maybe in the QA about the pros
and cons of those but the market-based
approach is what George Bush signed into
law and so that's what I want to talk
about because that's we've seen the
results so here's how we call it
cap-and-trade you I'm sure heard the
term how does it work
here's a little cartoon government sets
a hard cap off in a declining cap on
total allowable pollution and then
allowances are created for each ton
usually each unit of allowable pollution
those allowances are distributed to
emitters they can be distributed they
can be handed out for free that's what
happened in the acid rain case they can
be sold at auction that's what's done
all around the world and when this is
used for cap-and-trade for greenhouse
gas emissions the key is you have a
limited number of these allowances
you're creating scarcity and that gives
them value and then you're letting firms
trade the allowances because some firms
may be able to cut their emissions
more cheaply than others if they can do
that they can have excess allowances
they can sell to somebody else that
gives these allowances of value in the
market it creates that price signal you
need all happening under that cap or
that limit and of course this needs to
come with really clear monitoring and
recording and enforcement as is true of
any policy so that's how that sort of
cap and trade works in a nutshell I
talked about acid rain it's now
increasingly being used as a solution
for climate change this was a headline
from December 19th of last year that
China announced now it announced that it
was establishing plans to launch but
still China is on the road to having a
national cap and trade program those of
you may remember that the u.s. tried to
do this ten years ago I was really
involved in that at EDF before I went
into the administration we failed to get
that through the Congress so con so
climb up China is moving ahead and gonna
be creating the world's largest
pollution market at first covering its
electric power sector and then
explaining to the rest of the economy
the US there's not all bad news in the
US the u.s. actually California has a
cap-and-trade program under way that
just got strengthened and extended last
year we in this room the electricity
that powers the lights actually is under
a cap-and-trade program I'll be at a
pretty modest one that's in the nine
states of the Regional Greenhouse Gas
Initiative that'll be ten as soon as
governor phil murphy and new jersey
brings new jersey into the program and
virginia will also probably join soon so
the u.s. things are happening and if you
look globally the orange and red shows
the countries and jurisdictions that
have established markets in place China
has provincial systems and is going to
expand it to the rest of the world you
see a number of jurisdictions in fact
over 50 jurisdictions home to more than
a billion people more than one and a
half billion if you count all of China
or I guess two billion if you count all
China not just the provinces have those
carbon markets underway and there's lots
of other countries that have expressed
through that Paris process that they
want to have markets - so the blue
countries are countries that have
Express
interest in using markets to reduce
emissions in line with their Paris goals
sorry no this is a one that we made but
it shows its reflects for the World Bank
why one thing that I haven't said so far
that's worth maybe even ending on is why
an environmentalist is going on and on
and on and on about carbon markets and
and using economic incentives why don't
we just you know tell the regulator's
they gotta shut down I mean tell the
polluters they gotta shut down and you
know use the kind of conventional
regulation well one part of the story is
that the cap-and-trade markets that
we've had as in the acid rain story have
succeeded part of the story and a big
part of story for an environmentalist is
that the great thing about economic
instruments like a carbon market is that
they're cost-effective in the sense
they're allow us to do much more to
achieve any target at the lowest
possible cost by using a market you
create a real incentive to do things
more cheaply but it's more than that
it's also that if you use a market and
then you think about using those cost
savings to make investments in more
ambition more reductions you can
actually increase the amount of ambition
we do for any given amount of money so
what this analysis is is an early one
but it helps show why as an
environmental group should we care about
this we looked at the cost of achieving
the current pledges under the Paris
agreement and what that achieves it
achieves about 77 billion tons of
emissions reductions from now until 2035
that's our estimate if you take the cost
of doing that through the way that
countries are planning to do it and you
say well what if we used more markets
what if we just had a little bit more
markets in the asia-pacific region or
what if we had the americas come online
with markets or maybe if our heat map
scenarios if you look at all the mark of
the countries that we think you could
move soon what if everybody you had a
full global market we could do 30 to 90
percent more in terms of emissions
reductions if we use these market-based
approaches for the same amount of of
cost it would still be less than what we
need for two degrees so that's going to
require more ambition and more cost but
the use of markets will allow us to do
much more
so I'm actually gonna stop here my next
flight and last slide just says
political prospects in the US and that
might be a teaser for how we talk about
it but I want to stop there to give
plenty of time for questions and answers
[Applause]
stayed on this slide and then I could
have said well political prospects in
the u.s. so so the question just to
provide an additional piece of
background it's a great segue into a
discussion around political prospects
and I'm sure there'll be plenty else to
discuss I mentioned briefly this aborted
failed effort to pass cap-and-trade
legislation that would it you know back
in 2009-2010 that would have established
this kind of carbon market I'm talking
about for the entire US it was known as
the waxman-markey bill you may have
heard it passed the house that was a big
big win but it failed in the Senate the
US Climate Action Partnership that was
referred to was an effort by EDF and
other groups to bring a bunch of
businesses together and and join forces
with environmental groups to advocate
for well-designed climate policy the
theory being and we've seen this play
out in other places like California as
long as if you have the political will
so in California this has worked and in
you'll see where this fell short in the
US but if you have the political will to
establish the limit on greenhouse gas
emissions there's a strong incentive for
companies and businesses to want to do
that in the most flexible possible way
and these kind of carbon markets that
allow companies to buy to trade these
allowances under that cap to figure out
for themselves what makes the most sense
to make money off of pollution reduction
if they can that's a strong incentive
for them to join and advocate for that
so we had an effort that had you know
the biggest power companies that had a
couple of oil companies the car
companies and so on I used to have a
slide
you know that that showed all the
companies on it the really interesting
thing and it tells us a lot about
political prospects and they'll talk
about current prospects briefly you know
the theory of the case behind that
effort and we executed it really well
and the strategy was hatched in sort of
2000 to 2003 and it came to fruition
almost in 2009 2010 so that's the
timeframe the theory above the case was
if you're if you're going to pass
climate legislation in the US
you need to have Republicans on board
especially in the Senate and to get
Republicans in the Senate you need to
have business and if you had business
voices championing well-designed climate
policy you will get the votes you need
in the Senate what happened in my view
and we could spend a long time talking
about the sort of post-mortem I don't
like to do that anymore kind they did
enough of it in 2010 but what one of the
things that happen is American politics
shifted and if you think back now we've
seen eight years of really seeing that
shift but that was the front edge of the
shift American politics shifted and the
the Republican Party as it was
represented in Congress no longer was
the party of markets and big business
and responsiveness to those kind of
businesses coming in the Tea Party was
coming on board this was the spring of
2010 Tea Party was coming on the depths
of the recession we're still being felt
and the there were real cataclysmic
changes happening in the Republican
Party that I think really caused that
problem now so now fast forward to today
that creates a real question for us
because there's a temptation especially
for a group like EDF I showed you George
HW Bush we helped design that
cap-and-trade program that he signed
into law there's a temptation for groups
like EDF to think about the good old
days of the 1980s in the 1990s when
there were lots of Republicans national
Republicans who would be susceptible it
would be responsive to the idea of using
markets to solve environmental problems
it's not clear that we live in that
world anymore and the most challenging
political strategic question for
advocates is do we still go with a
bipartisan approach and try to figure
out how to create Republican champions
even in this today's Republican Party or
do we go
hard to the left and say we're just
going to try to get to a world where we
have 60 Democrats in the Senate and 218
in the house that's the fundamental
split in in the advocacy community you
can probably guess where EDF stands we
still think it's for well-designed and
durable policy we need to get Republican
votes but how to do that is a real
challenge and how to create the space in
the Republican Party for champions on
climate change is the most important
political challenge we have I'll tell
you one thing very briefly because I
know there'll be more questions there
are a few Chris Gibson who unfortunately
retired himself out termed himself out
in New York's Hudson River Valley was a
was a climate champion a Carlos corbello
from Maya from Florida's 26 district
lived in South Miami who sees and whose
constituents see you know what they call
sunny day flooding in Miami because sea
levels have risen high enough that you
get flooding in the streets even without
a storm
Carlos Capello is a champion on this in
the Republican Party one note of
optimism here is that what we see when
we talk to people like representative
Cabello we used to talk to people like
chris gibson for a certain brand of
republican in a purple swing district
who is looking to differentiate
themselves from the national party
without going so far that they get
primary doubt or shot down by the party
climate is the best and the polling data
back this up climate and the environment
generally in climate and specifically
has now become the best issue for them
to differentiate themselves on because
they can't step out on social issues
they can't step out for the most part on
guns they can't step out on immigration
anymore nationally I'm saying but
climate is increasingly an area where
they can step out and create some space
with the Republican Party and if that
continues to be the case that will be
that will help turn the tide on the
politics
the carbon tax means of all possible
solutions to climate change it seems
like the carbon tax is the most
conservative it's one that requires at
least perhaps amount of government
intervention or control and if in a red
Congress wouldn't make sense to advocate
for carbon tax
so part of the reason was just practical
in the sense that I already knew that I
was probably going to be pushing the
limits on an hour and I couldn't add
more slides there's but there's a couple
of reasons so I'll I there's a
long-running debate and to some degree I
think we need to get out of the debate
of a carbon tax versus a cap-and-trade
program there's a deep actually very
interesting debate in economics for
those of you he any students or
economists at heart they're very
interesting theoretical debate but I
think of it more on the politics side so
first I'll tell you why
you know EDF and I have traditionally
advocated for for cap-and-trade I think
of three reasons and then I'll get I
mean I'll do be brief and then I'll talk
about the Republican position
proposition you said first I ultimately
think this is a this is an issue about
limiting pollution into the atmosphere I
don't think this is about just putting a
price and not a limit and letting and
and hoping that the price you chose is
enough to avert catastrophe they're very
good and very smart I mean we could have
an economics debate here about that and
so they're good reason but I
fundamentally think as economists say I
think there's a quantity problem not a
price problem I am not willing to bet
the future of the planet that our models
that come up with that $48 a ton I'm not
willing to bet that those are right I'd
rather put a limit and let the market
decide what price is needed to meet that
limit so that's the economic reason then
the second is that is a domestic
political reason for why to prefer
cap-and-trade a discussion or in
cap-and-trade and again it's a hard one
as we saw we failed to pass it in the
Senate but a discussion around
cap-and-trade and a discussion around
limits
is a discussion it's a conversation
around protecting the health of the
planet
it's our week how much are we going to
limit pollution it's a conversation
about our children's safety their
children's safety safety of the planet
conversation about carbon tax is in
Apple I'm just talking pure politics the
conversation
carbon tax is how high is the price
going to be how much are we gonna raise
your electricity bill clearly from an
economic point of view they both put a
price on carbon both of those issues are
at stake but I'm just saying the for an
environmental advocate a I would much
rather have a conversation about what's
the safe level of pollution then what's
the affordable tax to put on energy and
so strategically that's that's a big
point and then the third point and then
I'll come back to your Republican
problem the third point is
internationally so you look at these
countries there's a really interesting
dynamic going on internationally which
is that countries are stand and
jurisdictions are starting to link out
California California has a formal link
between its system and Quebec and now
Ontario so they have a market that
trades these pollution allowances
between them Mexico yesterday maybe it
was today actually I just got the email
today but I don't know whether was
yesterday or today for my Mexico lead
Mexico has now passed the law to create
an emissions trading system in Mexico
because they want to link up with
California this is something pretty
interesting for economists in the room
by the way because our theory about why
you link markets is always about gains
from trade it's gonna be cheaper if a
high cost and the low cost jurisdiction
to coming up that's not what's happening
what's happening is that countries with
traditional ties economic trade ties
they both make ties sometimes it might
be cultural like California Mexico I
mean obviously there's differences in
cost but we're not talking about like
California linking up with like Mali
when I'm at California link up with
Canadian provinces and the reason is
political that there's a huge incentive
that the countries want to know that
others are at other countries or
jurisdictions are doing the same thing
and so carbon markets which lend
themselves to linking provide a very
powerful political magnetic pull in
theory you could do a tax and you could
harmonize the tax but that's not the
politics of it
you mentioned we even wouldn't
Republicans prefer attacks I have if you
show me a Republican who is advocating
for a tax then you know I will have that
conversation but it's it is it's it's
you're you're right that there's concern
Republic
get concerns that a cap-and-trade
program is going to be this big
government intervention and that's a
real thing we ran into with
waxman-markey like a buzzsaw but a tax
is not gonna solve that political
problem we could talk more right but I
want to if people are interested you ask
another question about the current tax
bills cuz they are coming it's an
excellent question you do hear this a
lot from many of my fellow advocates Oh
Paris was a signal to the world I don't
I don't I mean the parents of agreement
was terrific right it was it's a I
describe it as a framework for
international cooperation that for the
first time brought every brought every
country into that framework it
established the principle that every
country no Matt you know every country
should make a commitment to reducing
emissions it solved a lot of the issues
that had been really vexing
international negotiations for those of
you you know for a little bit of brief
background if you as you remember the
previous international agreement which
was the Kyoto Protocol was only agreed
to with under the Kyoto Protocol every
country agreed to it basically except
the u.s. never ratified it but only
developed countries as that term was
defined in 1992 only developed countries
had to do anything and that might have
it might have made sense in 1992 that
the u.s. needed to do something in China
didn't but by 2007 when the Kyoto
Protocol took effect the China China was
already the world's largest emitter or
was maybe took over took the u.s. in
2008-2009 so it's crazy to have a system
where only one small set of countries
has to do anything in so so Paris was a
huge step in the right direction and
firms are going to respond to the
policies that their national governments
put into place
and the signal from the Paris agreement
I don't think it was zero but it's not
as if you know
ExxonMobil woke up the next day and sort
of said oh my gosh we can no longer sell
oil petroleum the real signal needs to
come from national governments
implementing their pledges and
implementing their commitments and and
then doing more going beyond those
commitments and again I think if you
have an economic signal through
something like the price and a
cap-and-trade program that'll be even
more powerful so carbon offsets for
those of you who who haven't studied
this deeply there's an the idea is if
let's say one one jurisdiction like
California puts a cap and trade program
in place this limit on pollution I
talked about that limit covers in
California's case the limit covers all
the electric power facilities excuse me
the industrial facilities covers
transportation almost all of
California's emissions are covered and
facilities in California you know as I
described in my little cartoon every
year they need to come up with enough
allowances to cover the previous year's
emissions an offset program says ok one
way you can meet your compliance
obligation if you're in California are
afraid in Europe you know wherever
you're subject to that you can meet that
obligation by using credits that were
generated from emissions reductions
somewhere else that offset so you can
offset your emissions with a credit
generated somewhere else whether or not
that is good policy depends on two
fundamental things one is the mechanics
of how those offsets are measured and
generated so you've got to be really
sure that you're accurately measuring
emissions that you can measure you can
tell the difference you know it that you
can you can attribute where the
reductions are you've got to make sure
that that offset doesn't get sold twice
so there are a lot of technical things
around making that offset work but
there's another broader issue which is
you have to there have if those offsets
are purely in a sit in a context where a
country that doesn't need to do any
thing can reduce its emissions and then
sell those offsets into it into a
country that's taken on a target it
becomes very hard to figure out whether
those emissions reductions are things
that were happening because of the
program or would have happened anyways
and so you have a real risk that with
that in creating offsets you're actually
giving credit for things that would have
happened already and and solving that is
is hard having said that I think there
are some approaches to offsets where the
things that look like offsets it's
actually sort of really moving towards
it looks more and more like linking
markets that I think could satisfy both
of those conditions and the leading one
is in the case of tropical forests so I
mentioned you know mostly when you think
about solving climate change you think
about industry or steel or
transportation or power but forests are
also a huge part of the solution of the
huge part of emissions and a huge part
of the solution in fact I assured you
before Brazil and Indonesia were two of
those sort of three really big
opportunities to turn the corner and the
estimates are that if you if we were
able to eliminate tropical deforestation
and start to restore degraded for us we
could achieve about 30 that would that
would account for about 30 percent of
global emissions so you could get 30
percent of global emissions reductions
effectively from from forests how are
you going to do that well one way to do
that is to measure emissions reductions
from reduce deforestation in places like
Brazil in the Amazon or Indonesia and if
you can measure them before rigorous
baselines and you do that in the context
of the Paris agreement where Brazil is
taking on a national target if Brazil
could beat its target by reducing
emissions from deforestation by more and
get credit for that reduction and then
those credits could have value in a
market in California or somewhere else
that would be a huge economic incentive
to protect the forests so the it's a
long-winded answer partly because the
mechanics of making offsets work is
really important but in the case of
forests credits you've got the
monitoring and verification technology I
think you have the policy structure in
place to make it work and I think that
would be a critical part
joe-joe very interesting question the
question if you didn't hear it is I
talked about Tea Party in terms of
Republican changes and how much did
Citizens United make a change so I'm not
an expert on campaign finance my
understanding and some and the people
I've seen who say this people like Larry
Kramer who's the head of the Hewlett
Foundation used to be the Dean of
Stanford Law School I think when he when
people like this say what I'm about to
say they're saying it partly to be
provocative but I've seen a lot of smart
people say citizen united did not have a
significant impact and the reason is if
you remember citizen united was only
about corporate giving and if you think
about a lot of the dark money or
whatever the the song you know the the
money that's gone into politics and
really changing things a lot of that is
from private individuals and so citizen
united I'm sure had an impact but was
that decision the defining thing I don't
think so now camping what's that exactly
so I was just gonna say there's a
broader question about campaign finance
that goes back further about you know
unlimited campaign yeah that I was about
to say campaign finance has played a
role but the Citizens United as much as
it's you know a target of progressives I
don't I don't think that's been the
major issue Barry what you're an
economist you like reading from other
principles to bear and we as a former
college we tax good things like incomes
and we don't tax bad things like carbon
if we're going to have to budget
deficits and we need more revenue why
not I'm gonna pushing more on the idea
starting off with revenue neutral carbon
taxes and use that as a way to reduce
income tax so I think so as an economist
you know if I could draw up the system I
would use I would have a revenue neutral
cap-and-trade program
I'd used the cap-and-trade program
because I wouldn't want a cap but you
can raise revenue by you know selling
you generate these allowances you can
sell them at auction California does
that that's a equivalent way of raising
revenue as tax you mean in terms of the
revenue you raise and I do think from an
economic point of view be make a lot of
sense to be raising that revenue from
putting a price on pollution and then
using it to reduce the taxes we put on
income and other goods I told I
completely agree is that politically
feasible I don't know and I hope it is
but I'm you know but but that's that's
going to be determined basically this
right and have absolutely zero impact
today so we have so it yeah in the in
the atmosphere often talk about like
what the opinions the matter the people
with voting cards and so I think there's
a strategic question about how much we
push that versus the the cap I will tell
you our advocacy and again the
economists will appreciate this in the
room our advocacy in the carbon tax
world understanding that now the
discussion in Washington is really
around carbon taxes rather than cap and
trade programs and we go into that our
advocacy in the carbon tax world is
actually about how to turn a carbon tax
into something that looks a little bit
more like it gives the guarantees we'd
like to see on environmental performance
so imagine a carbon tax that instead of
just setting the tax and setting the
path of the tax over the next you know
20 30 years whatever and then walking
away and hoping you got you got the
right tax imagine a carbon tax that has
a performance expectation that basically
says if emissions haven't been reduced
by this mount by such and such a year
the tax will automatically ratchet up
now I thought this was a brilliant
creative idea until I discovered that
Switzerland already has this kind of tax
not surprising to an advocate every
opportunity every time they it came time
to compare how far the tax said cut
emissions to the benchmark they
to raise the tax so I think that
justifies the view that we ought to have
some performance guarantees and attacks
but to your point Barry I I agree I and
there are more one of the good news
stories about us politics is there are
more and more voices in here and so
there are a lot of voices that are
saying a carbon tax ought to be revenue
neutral I think that's great you know
ETF's voice is gonna focus on let's make
sure we get the environmental outcomes
but if I could write up the result I
would have it be revenue neutral there
was one more in back there's a lot of
interesting things happening in biofuels
some good and some bad
I mentioned in passing I may have
mentioned if I didn't I should have the
aviation sector one of the most
interesting places actually where policy
is going on in these markets and in
offsets is the aviation sector where an
area where we've done a lot of work at
EDF and it's still in the balance about
whether there's offset rules are going
to be right or not the basic idea is to
a year and a half ago the Avia
International Civil Aviation
Organization ICAO which is a UN body
that governs international aviation
agreed to put a carbon neutral limit on
emissions from international aviation
and implement that through a
market-based measurement that uses
offsets what offset says are still to be
determined which is why your question is
a good one
so the ICAO is normally the body most of
the things they do like the standards
they do are like the bolts that hold the
wing onto the plane and you know the
size of the coffee machine so it doesn't
spill out and scald people like that's
like air stuff so now they're getting
into the carbon and so one of the issues
that they've looked at obviously is
biofuels because one of the ways they
would like to meet that carbon neutral
target is by using something other than
jet fuel but the challenge with biofuels
is you've got to grow the stuff
somewhere and so suppose you say you
know and so suppose you decide to
instead of putting planting you know
soybeans in a particular plot you're
gonna plant the biofuel crop well unless
we think that biofuels make people eat
you know fewer soybeans some of these
get somebody else is going to cut down
some forests or they're gonna replace
some land somewhere to grow those
soybeans so the point is that the
land-use impacts of biofuels are
enormous and thinking about whether we
actually have the land capacity without
cutting down all our forests to grow
enough biofuels to really make it a
viable solution that's a big challenge
I'm not as familiar on all the numbers
there's a guy named Tim if you're
interested in a guy named Tim searching
her and Princeton who's written a lot on
this but the point is biofuels are one
of those technologies where there's a
lot of promise but we really need to get
the rules right and that's probably a
good place to end because I know Francis
is right here but it's a good example of
getting the rules right and getting the
incentives right so that we align the
private interests there with what's
actually good for the climate in the
planet I think the you know the the I
always think of two words which are hope
and optimism I'm kind of in veteran
partly that's why I'm in the business I
am and I have to be to keep going you
know this is an enormous challenge that
we face and all the gloom and doom I
gave you in the beginning is was there
for a reason and you know I talked about
turning the corner and and getting on
that downward trajectory is going to be
incredibly challenging but I do think if
we put the solution to policy solutions
in place and we can harness the
ingenuity of you know the modern-day
john williams's and clock makers I think
we can make a lot of headway in solving
this problem we have what it takes to
turn the corner and start reducing
emissions and I think we just need to
put the political will and the resources
behind that
[Applause]
[Music]